the demon souls remake for ps5 is an
exciting prospect for long time fans and
newcomers alike
it offers the chance to relive a
beautiful new version of from software
seminal souls game or to check out the
game that laid out the template for from
software's titles for the very first
time
but naturally there are a lot of
questions surrounding the details of the
remake effort
after all it's being handled by blue
point games alongside sony interactive
entertainment worldwide studios
blue point games is called the master of
the remaster having knocked it out of
the park with shadow of the colossus and
metal gear solid hd collection among
others
but a completely remade souls game not
involving from software
still makes fans nervous thankfully i
was able to talk to gavin moore
creative director at sie world world
studios external development and get
some answers to a few of my big
questions
having done so i feel a little more at
ease about the game
especially having learned about some of
the new features and tweaks
so settle in here are 8 things you need
to know about the demon souls remake
first up you might want to know the
history of the project and how much from
software is involved
according to moore it was blue point's
work on shadow of the colossus which he
said
redefined what a remix should be that
gave sony the confidence and knowledge
to take on demon
souls it started development immediately
after shadow of the colossus that game
was released in february 2018
but imagine production on demon souls
started much before that
on the playstation blog moore said that
the game has been in development for
three years
as for from software's involvement the
japanese developer and the game's
director hirotaka miyazaki gave their
blessing for the project to go forward
however they were not involved in the
day-to-day production which was handled
entirely by worldwide studios
and bluepoint we made sure that we
stayed true to their original vision
that's incredibly important you know
we're massive fans of miyazaki games
and so you know making sure that you
know what we created was true to his
vision wasn't you know
that was the golden standard so how much
of the game has changed
and how does blue point make sure it's
staying true to the original well the
answer to that is by both sony and blue
point being their own worst critics
according to moore
we don't put anything in this game
without you know really thinking about
how it
affects the core of the game and how it
affect that experience
and that is true to every aspect of the
game
in our interview more specifically
called out the ps5 features like haptics
visual upgrades and audio upgrades
saying that they needed to figure out
how they could use those in a way that
makes
sense in terms of combat it was
important not to change the cadence of
animations because that changes the
gameplay
and the game however moore did say that
the repulse animation shown during the
gameplay is something new that the team
has added
with proper consideration given
demon souls remake has a bunch of new
animations for different weapon types
so a spear pole arm rapier and katana
will have distinct attacks
akin to the lift and slam attack shown
in the gameplay demo
importantly however more said the
cadence is all the same as the original
so the gameplay
doesn't change the speed of the attack
is the same you're just
visually just adding you know extra
details and flourishes to really
bring that world alive one of the things
that i was really curious about was how
the ps5 solid state drive changes the
feel of the game as we saw in the
gameplay video loading and by extension
fast traveling around was
really really quick however there's a
certain kind of pacing and cadence that
is important to souls games when you die
you have the time to reflect and feel
the weight of what happened
there's so much you can feel in the time
it takes to get back into the game
so how does effectively eliminating or
at least shortening the downtime
impact the game as a whole according to
moore the team has paid attention to the
timing on certain aspects of the game
so for example traveling on an elevator
is still going to take the same amount
of time as it did in the original
this is because it's important to build
tension and think about what's ahead
that has not changed however
instantaneous loading is being used to
let the player
jump into the game quicker so loading
from the nexus into a location will be
quick because you just want to get from
an archstone to 1-1 and when you die
the game will hold a moment for a beat
to provide that time to reflect
it's just enough to take a breather
prepare and get back into it
so it seems they've paid close attention
to the pacing of downtime too
one thing that fans picked up on in the
gameplay demo was the rolls during the
vanguard battle
during this fight the player character
can be seen diving in a way that
suggested that 4-way rolling would be
back from the original when locked on
of course in that time since souls games
have become less restrictive with
evasive maneuvers available to the
player
so i asked if the remake was sticking to
the letter of the original's law or if
it was being updated
sony and blueprint previously said that
the game was going to appeal
to players that are accustomed to modern
controls and as part of that
moore confirmed that the remake will
have omni-directional evasion so you can
roll in eight directions
you know we had to make sure that we
made uh you know life improvements
to the game that people expected and
then added that making the changes
didn't
make a big difference to gameplay or the
core in any way and it was just what
people wanted
the other things that fans have been
talking about is the camera which looked
a bit different in the gameplay video it
had a bit more of a
cinematic feeling and framing more
confirmed that yes the camera has been
changed the camera from the original
demon souls as players will know had a
tendency to get stuck
on collision or would clip through the
walls which is less acceptable these
days so it had to be altered
however if you really miss it the
developers have included the option to
switch to the old camera so
in mods onwards if you don't like what
we've done we've left the old system in
there so if you want to switch to that
then please switch to
from its that
let strength be granted so the world
might be mended
if you watched the gameplay demo and
picked up on what sounded like added
dialogue from the maiden in black then
well done
gold star to you blue point and sony are
adding some new content when it comes to
writing and spoken dialogue
according to more one of the things that
the team noticed was the lack of variety
and voice over so characters would say
the same thing over and over
to remedy this the developers have added
variety what that means is that the
characters are conveying the same
information
but they're just saying it in a
different way so they feel more alive
and more natural
which is a kind of ethos that we've been
trying to do with the whole game
blueprint and sony went out and found as
many of the original cast as they could
and got them to come back and perform
their iconic roles once again
as well as voicing the new stuff all the
dialogue has been re-recorded
for the audiophiles out there it's worth
knowing that blueprint and sony have
remade thousands and thousands of sound
effects
to add into levels then using 3d audio
on ps5 brought that to life
[Applause]
more said that you'll be able to hear
arrows fly past your head and hear
creatures crawl out of slime in the
valley of deferment
sounds gross honestly
okay so yes blue point did change the
tower knight and flame lurker scene
shown in the gameplay demo
fans noted that the tower knight battle
felt a bit more bright and heroic than
in the original
while the flame locker looked to have
had its face changed entirely
after seeing the response the developers
agreed that the flame locker at least
was a step
too far and tweaked it to be closer to
the original so they are listening to
your criticisms
just remember to keep it constructive
one thing that i learned was demon souls
remake will have a number of filters
that you can play the game with
including black and white
one of the filters is a classic one so
you can use that if you'd like an
experience that harkens back to the ps3
version of the game
it's a starker and darker look that
according to moore drives a little bit
more fear into the game
more did say that he would like fans to
play through the game in the way sony
and blue point have remade at first
though just so they can see the power of
the ps5
and the treatment that they've given the
game so will demon souls have a respec
option not really but there does seem to
be a character switching option that may
allow for the use of multiple builds
more was a bit vague about it owing to
wanting to maintain some mystery around
it and also because we were rapidly
running out of time but here's what he
said
um what we have done is we've allowed
you to create you know we've updated the
character creator
when we've given thousands of thousands
of new permutations to everyone you can
create and you can play
once you've chosen a character what you
can do is
um after you've paid a number of souls
for it in the nexus you can actually
kind of store your character and
then go in and change your character in
the nexus
that's the quick interpretation i'll
leave it up to you to find out where it
is and how you do it
of course that is something completely
new to the game and we'll have to see
how it works in the game and find out
what the implications are when it's out
okay here are a few final things worth
noting about demon souls remake
kind of in a spitfire round fraction
mode has been a big mystery but no
longer
it's a fractured world that effectively
serves as a mirror mould where the map
is reversed
it sounds like it's a harder version
designed to pull the rug out from
underneath veteran players
on top of that there is no easy option
in the game there is no easy option in
demon souls it's true to the original
the reaper scythe pre-order bonus
doesn't make the game trivial as some
feared
moore also said that we have added new
content to the game hinting out more
additional weapons potentially
but everything that was in the ps3
version is in the standard edition of
the game so you won't be missing out on
the core experience
after that the old monk fight which
leverages online connectivity to turn
another player into a boss will work the
same as in the original
wall tendency is also exactly the same
the only thing that the developers have
done
is to adjust the ui to make it a little
bit easier for the player to understand
which state the world tendency is in the
healing system is also the same
so prepare to chew on some grass and
finally the all-important question
is blue point fixing the sixth arch
stone in the nexus and restoring the
content here's what moore said so
that was a long and hard discussion
um there is no sixth art stone there are
only five archetypes in the nexus it's
true to the original there's no
new arsenal there's no new world so
there you have it eight things that fans
need to know about the demon souls
remake for ps5
you can bet we'll be covering it
extensively on gamespot.com and here on
youtube.com4slashgamespot if you haven't
check out the written version of this
interview on gamespot.com
hit me up on twitter at tomorrow h and
i'll see you all in the nexus
[Music]
you